For many people, the history of space exploration
often feels like a very American story.
And while the moon landing is rightly placed
as the shiny gold medal, the Russian cosmonaut
program was incredibly successful and achieved
many firsts that are too often overlooked;
Moscow, we have a problem.
These days, space exploration is a much more
collaborative process and is often controlled
by private businesses rather than governments.
Although perhaps Elon Musk is building an
evil moon base and will become our cosmic
overlord.
So today we’re looking at some of the biggest
contributions Russia made to mankind’s exploration
of space.
The founding father of rocketry and aeronautics
was Konstantin Tsiolkovsky, a partially deaf
scientist who was home-schooled and ended
up living as a recluse in a log cabin south
of Moscow.
He believed that life in space was the future
of mankind, where we could live forever and
be free from all our worries, sort of like
a floating Disneyland.
He seemingly thought about every aspect of
space travel; from steering thrusters and
a multi-stage booster system to airlocks and
even the closed system of biology you would
need to make self-sustaining food systems.
In 1903 he published Exploration of Outer
Space by Means of Rocket Devices and in it
he calculated that you would need a speed
of 8000m/s in order to hold a minimal earth
orbit.
He showed how this could be achieved with
a multi-stage rocket fueled by liquid oxygen
and liquid hydrogen, using an earlier formula
he had created to show how the mass lost though
burning fuel affects a body’s acceleration.
He was the first person to show that space
travel was actually possible, rather than
just a Jules Verne fantasy.
Not sure the same will happen with the whole
Journey to the Centre of the Earth thing though,
Jules, it’s bloody hot down there.
Tsiolkovsky inspired many others, including
the German, Hermann Oberth, and American,
Robert H. Goddard, who built the first liquid
fueled rocket.
But within Russia, Sergei Korolev was his
greatest disciple and went on to lead the
Soviet Space program.
Korolev started out as an aircraft designer
but in 1938 he was arrested as part of Stalin’s
great purge, where Stalin cleared out the
communist party of anyone who might oppose
him.
By the time Korolev’s appeal was awarded,
he had already spent months in a Siberian
gulag, starving to death down a mine.
He lost many of his teeth thanks to scurvy
and just generally had a really great time.
His death sentence was overturned and he spent
5 years in a Sharashka, which was basically
a prison for brainboxes so they could be punished
but the country could still benefit from their
expertise.
It’s similar to how many university professors
feel today.
He began work on rocket boosters, because
apparently just escaping prison with a ladder
would not have been good enough for him.
After World War 2, he worked on trying to
understand and improve the German V2 missile
design and eventually, in 1957, the R-7 Semyorka
successfully launched, the world’s first
true intercontinental ballistic missile.
On the back of this success, he persuaded
Khrushchev, then leader of Russia, to allow
him to launch a satellite and beat the Americans
to the punch.
In just a month they cobbled together a metal
sphere with a transmitter, a few instruments
and batteries, and on 4 October 1957, Sputnik
became the first ever satellite, launched
on a modified R-7 rocket.
Sputnik is the Russian for satellite but was
previously used to mean “travelling companion”.
Sputnik 2 contained the dog Laika, the first
animal in space, who died of heat exhaustion
in just hours.
Sputnik 3 launched but its instruments failed,
which were intended to map the Van Allen radiation
belts.
The west continued to obliviously label every
subsequent Russian satellite or space station
as Sputnik 4, 5, 6 etc. even though in Russia
they had proper names for them.
Belka and Strelka were the first animals to
successfully return from space and you can
actually visit their little stuffed bodies
in the Memorial Museum of Cosmonautics, in
Moscow.
Around 50 dogs were used in the program, mainly
mongrel mutts as they were more resilient
and predominantly female ones as they were
better behaved.
The final test flight was in the Vostok 3KA-2,
when a dog named Zvezdochka along with a human
sized dummy named Ivan Ivanovich, returned
from a low earth orbit.
Korolev really wanted to follow Tsiolkovsky’s
big ambition and head straight for Mars but
the Space Race with the Americans meant that
politics decided what the aims should be,
so the Moon became the target.
The rate of achievement was phenomenal, as
both sides pushed to achieve a series of firsts.
There was barely any testing and deadlines
were suddenly dragged forward as news from
the other side came in.
Luna 2 was the first space probe to land on
Mars, after they missed by 6000 km with Luna
1, everyone needs a warm up shot, I guess.
Luna 3 gave us the first shots of the far
side of the moon but it was 14 years before
Pink Floyd released the soundtrack, so they
were a bit too early.
And then on 12 April 1961, the big one, the
first human to leave the planet; Yuri Gagarin.
The whole trip in the Vostock 1 took just
108 minutes, including the time it took him
to parachute down from 7 kilometers up.
But even for such a short trip, Gagarin stopped
the bus on the way to the rocket to take a
quick, preparatory leak, a tradition which
is now continued on every Russian mission;
a Urine Gagarin, if you will.
And the Russians sent empty bladders up on
a pretty regular basis from then on, as they
crossed off many other firsts such as Alexey
Leonov’s spacewalk and Valentina Tereshkova
flying the female flag in space, beating the
American Sally Ride by almost exactly 20 years.
Interestingly, Sally is still the youngest
American to leave earth, at 32 but Gagarin
was just 27 and Gherman Titov was only 25,
the first to spend a day in space.
And what about the future?
Well there are a range of orbiters and landers
being sent up to the moon but this seems to
just be a bit of warm up.
The exciting things in the pipeline are various
collaborations with NASA, yes that’s right,
Russia is collaborating with NASA.
The Kremlin also put 1.5 million dollars into
planning a mission to Ganymede, Jupiter’s
largest moon.
Of course, we all know the big secret that
the Russian space program have been hiding
from us; that if you open up a Russian rocket,
you find another slightly smaller rocket hiding
inside, and then another smaller rocket, it’s
a very clever system.